hangs up guys my name is just gonna
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we talked about layers and we
made the whole layer stack system make
sure you check that out if you haven't
already and now that we've got all of
that what I would like to kind of
proceed with them in the direction that
I want to take this right now in the
next steps is actually getting I am GUI
running if those of you join I'm GUI is
like a it's a it's an immediate mode
kind of GUI system so if you haven't
checked out my open GL stories video
online could we definitely that out do I
be linked up there as well it just lets
us kind of really easily kind of
immediate mode a GUI GUI in just as that
we can like debug things or click on
buttons and have things happen it's a UI
right that's what it lets us do and it's
really easy to use if for me that's one
of the first things that I love setting
up in a game engine or any kind of
really like any kind of graphics project
really because being able to kind of
both see information as well as kind of
adjust values or kind of make things
happen that's like I couldn't live
without that like I don't think that's
possible like I don't want it for
example recompile code every time I want
to change a variable right item I have a
little slider on the screen that kind of
stuff it's really useful for that and
definitely not that urban jealous or a
video that I may not I am doing what
kind of some familiarize you guys with
that if you haven't heard of it yet or
you can't kind of imagine why something
like that might actually be useful all
right anyway so in order to get iron GUI
actually working though what we need to
do more we don't need to do this but
we're going to do this first because
it's going to more or less future-proof
how I'm going implementation we need a
way to actually use modern OpenGL so
right now the graphics API that we're
kind of going with is OpenGL hazel will
be kind of the architecture of hazel
will for sure support any kind of
graphics API right right now it's just
gonna be OpenGL to begin with there's a
lot of reasons for that I think it
covered that in the planning video and
don't worry like it's not gonna be it's
not gonna be really it's not gonna be
hard at all for us like switch develop
in or like you know add on DirectX that
should be really quite easy
like a day's worth of work but in the
beginning we're gonna go with OpenGL
just because is both the simplest API
that is out there and also it's kind of
it's the most cross-platform API that we
actually have at the moment that it's
also that level of simplicity right sir
DirectX 11 you could argue is not that
difficult as well whereas Vulcan is more
or less on DirectX 12 level which is a
lot more lower level however DirectX 11
wasn't only about blowing windows and I
want people to easily be able to port
this to other platforms especially
because we have pre-made set up it
should just work pretty much rather than
think we're using any window specific
code anyway all right I don't want to
spend this episode talking about what
we're doing basically what we need to do
is we need a way to load all of the
modern OpenGL functions from our GPU
drivers into just our C++ code right so
I want to be able to call functions that
are stored inside our graphics drivers
that's basically the idea now in the
OpenGL series we did we used something
called jail aw glue which is the up in
jail like extension wrangling there's a
link in the top left corner as well to
that video in case you want to check out
that but this in this series for this
engine I'm actually gonna use something
different I'm actually gonna use
something called glad which is I don't
know stands for something it probably
does it just says multi language GL
order generator based on the official
specs anyway it's a little bit better
and more modern in my experience than
glue glue is something that I used to
use coming in the past but this is a
little bit more configurable and it's
just a little bit I just like it a
little bit more but but I just want you
to know that there's a real difference
like for example the opengl series is
kind of the little framework what we
have there is built using glue where as
am using glass for this they do the same
thing i don't think it's my lamp if
you'll notice how you performance
differences or anything like that
i'm just gonna use glad yeah because
it's a little bit more modern but apart
from that basically the function of both
these things is to check out our kind of
graphics drive a dll and just load
certain functions that we know are in
there so that we can then call them from
our c++ code that is what these
libraries do let's take a look at how we
can set this up its shoot
dead simple we're going to actually
configure it using the website first
then download it then add it as a
separate project and then add a premade
file to it so that it is a separate
project and we're just gonna commit it
as part of our repository so it's not
gonna be like a fork from another
repository like I did it with sheriff W
and like I'm going to do with I'm go as
well all right let's just jump into it
okay so this website that we have here
I'm gonna link in the description below
but basically just license kind of
configure what we actually want the
glaad file to look like so this would
actually generate some code for us
essentially so the language of course
will be C C++ OpenGL is going to be our
specification we're gonna go with the
core cabal to get the fluid with the
core profile because we don't want any
kind of compatibility functions which
means we don't want it to support
deprecated functions the API I'm gonna
go with core 4.6 right for GL extensions
I don't really right now is very
difficult for me to say that I want
certain extensions because this will
most likely lend itself when we get to
optimizing things all we want to do some
fancy things like I don't know just like
sharing memory between directx and
opengl potentially stuff like that
most of these extensions should not be I
don't people need any of them right now
so and obviously once we do need them we
can just regenerate this file so that's
kind of settings as I'm using right now
4.6 GL OpenGL of course and then the
core profile so now all I have to do is
will generate a loader I'll just hit
generate and in this will create this
kind of web page here I'm going to just
click on Gilad dot zip to download it
and then that should pretty much have
everything we need so if I open that we
have including source ok so I'm going to
copy that
inside hazel I'm gonna go to our
[Music]
solution directory here I'm gonna go
into hazel I'm gonna go into vendor I'm
gonna make a new folder called glad I
want to paste that in there and you can
see that the I mean there's one source
file it's quite large and then they'll
there's also like a bunch of include
files we probably won't need cash are at
all
glad delay is just kind of what we're
looking at and then that's kind of kind
of it right so all we need to do now is
make a pre make file and then add kind
of this pre make file into our pre make
file so if I open up this pre make file
I've set pre make file about five times
and four seconds there anyway you can
see that we include you know this one we
also are going to essentially be
including glad right and then these
include directories as well I'm going to
duplicate it so that we have Vlad here
and then you know when we come down here
to include certain things hopefully you
guys are enjoying this live carding
because I know a lot of people looking
complaining about that I'll try and do a
lot of coding as much as I can but
sometimes it just gets a little bit
difficult will link glad as well a good
idea or just of such kind of for
wherever GL fw is and then just maybe
see if we need to do the same for glad
that's going to be my my pro strat right
now yeah it looks pretty good okay so I
mean the the biggest thing is we need to
link it as a project because of course
it's going to compile into a static
library and then also we need to make
sure that the include directories are
actually e now include directories for
hazel that's pretty much it okay so
that's done now we need to actually make
a pre make file for glass so what I'll
do is if I go into job W I can just kind
of steel that pre make file put it in
here and then we can take a look at what
it looks like so the project name would
be glad this is actually a I'll actually
glad is this a project as well isn't it
one language is glamour in it it is say
okay great so this is gonna be quite
similar it's gonna be a static library
project name is glad
ALPA directory is the same right now
files in include we have black Gladwell
H so include glad is there it's just
like HG la D quad quad ships
I want to actually be quite explicit
with the files here
ka-chow include educational platform I
mean I could just obviously have it
include everything kind of like what we
have with hazel but I do want to
actually be explicit here just so that a
little bit more aware glad see because
we should only have three balls anyway
okay so that's it those are the three
files the clack kind of has I don't
think I made any mistakes here no that
looks good this stuff I don't really
want any of this to be honest so kind of
I don't think we need any of this really
means Dacron time and stuff we will need
I'm not gonna do multi-threaded oh okay
I'll kind of get rid of this and this
should obviously be latest I probably
should update if y'all have told you to
be that as well no build options at all
and the last thing I want to do is
actually add this include directory to
the include does that we have here sir
inclu alright and that is it
one thing I want to do actually because
I've kind of just looked at this website
and realized that glad really isn't all
in other cases maybe I do actually want
to make it more kind of lowercase e so
if we go back to our other przemek file
I'll just maybe make this glad like that
and probably change the folder name as
well because I don't think it stands for
anything apparently or at least the
website implies that it doesn't so we're
gonna make sure that any places is glad
it's in the correct way good and then if
we go to disk
I'm not sure if this to let us rename
okay if good just because in Windows of
course directory names and file names
are not case-sensitive okay cool
so there we go we've got everything here
we this should just work what we can do
now is just try and regenerate our
projects and then hopefully everything
will just work so we didn't get any
rights from pre make if we reload it
we should get glad here okay fantastic
and then apart from having all of our
files here which is perfect we should
also see that hazel now references glad
which it does so you can see that was me
kind of making a premix script pretty
much from memory I mean it did copy and
paste job w1 but you can see just how
simple um Pro make is I love preemie
okay let's build our whole solution and
see what happens and okay once excited
fantastic so everything's excited so now
all we really need to do to use glad is
initialize it right so there is a
function inside here that lets us
actually load something okay that's not
I think it's glad jail Lord or something
I'm glad Lord Lord there it is okay so
this if we specified this and I wish
that this had not even there don't think
I remember where the documentation is
for this stuff um if we look at github
maybe we'll see how to use it anyway I
know how to use it because I've used it
before but essentially what we need to
do is just call this function with the
Lord kind of function that we have that
will allow us to load kind of dll files
or functions from there so to do that
I'm just going to go into windows window
and then over here is where we kind of
initialize jail FW and also create the
OpenGL context
so once we've kind of made that context
that's where I kind of want to actually
do the glad stuff so we'll do glad Lloyd
Rio Laura
and let me just quickly include glad
first of all so it's an include part so
we should just be able to say glad glad
don't H like that it's gonna be a low
case and then glad GL lota of course
needs a collab Lord proc and then the
function that we're gonna give it is
actually gel W
it's actually gel W get proper dress
like that okay and then all we'll do is
well do a chorus set here on status and
then you know fail to initialize glad or
something like that
NHGRI's okay cool so that should be
pretty much all that we need to do we're
gonna put a breakpoint here and then hit
f5 to run this code arrow and Jeff had
are already included okay cool so I
really think Levi already provides it so
I'm happy that we're including opengl
twice let's see what this is actually
happening so here J love W is included I
don't know why we did that cuz I don't
think we need any of it what I'm gonna
do is probably end up doing something
like this so we'll do stripes gel W
window here just to get that and then
include gel over here after glad it
doesn't there's probably a way to just
not have it include gel because yeah I'm
sure you can tell it not to because
there's gel be included on so I think
that maybe we should just do that
so inside hazel and that's right when it
isn't pretty make don't we so we'll go
back to hazel we'll go back to pre meg
and then one of the defines that we will
use somewhere here where are our defines
for system windows so I don't know if I
wanted is just for windows my medias in
the windows window for now yeah let's
just put it here we'll do Java EE
including on okay and that just will not
include any gel W it will not include
any OpenGL headers when you include your
value
that's the idea so now if we under this
and we have glad here what I mean this
try and build this it should work no
it's not working
okay open jail header or oh well of
course I didn't regenerate the projects
so let's generate the projects where you
load this try and compile all that and
there you go okay it succeeded fantastic
so now with our breakpoint in place
let's hit f5 okay it's not happy with
these clear calls because we're
including this black Michael H cuz glad
now has all about OpenGL defines let's
see if we get any other errors no f5
there is our breakpoint and status is
one okay which obviously means it
succeeded because we're setting if it's
not zero we're setting that is not zero
okay fantastic so we can basically say
that that's it it's all done another way
to quickly check which is maybe a little
bit hacky but if we try I think window
create should create everything right so
if we try and do something like JAL
Chandra x-ray is clearly something that
is clearly something that is sign names
something that is modern OpenGL then
first of all this function should not be
null right so yeah it executed and it
gave us a valid ID so you can say that
everything what successfully all right
so that is how we set up glad I don't
think I need to go over the changes with
you guys let me push to github beacon
over the changeable yourselves but yeah
so that is glad and then in the next
episode we'll be able to use glad to
actually implement I'm GUI using modern
urban GL
alright so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you can hit the like
button also huge thank you to all the
patreon supporters that made this series
possible if you're not supporting the
stereo on patreon definitely go check
that out huge thank you to you guys as
always you'll get all the episodes a
week early as well as access to my kind
of private
branch in which I've already done all of
this work so you can kind of see like
months and months ahead as to whether
this engine is going and you can kind of
I mean I kind of as when I work on that
I also kind of you know commit as I go
so you can see minimal changes you don't
need to be like okay now I've got this
complete engine and I don't know how it
works so you can kind of go back if you
can miss and just see kind of how it
evolves as well because that that kind
of development branch is largely where
this series is going I do make changes
like here there but you mostly it's the
same so if you're interested definitely
check that out okay so that's glad it's
it's pretty straightforward it's pretty
easy to set up pre make makes this
really easy as you can say as well so I
love that in the next episode we're
gonna take a look at basically having a
very basic implementation of I'm going
another thing is we're gonna add on GUI
the sub module and obviously do all that
stuff and we're actually going to take
their example OpenGL implementation and
go from there and probably there I'm not
gonna I'm gonna reference their example
jail fw implementation but i'm not going
to just take it word for word because i
want actually make an i'm doing layout
which has all of that stuff basically
because they only need to you know do
all of the old the gfw neutralization
that should be extracted in window so
we're gonna kind of hacky and i'm going
next episode because it's way too early
for us to be able to do it properly the
reason is we don't have a renderer at
the moment okay and obviously we need to
be able to do things like compile
shaders right so but i want to get i'm
going up and running because we'll be
able to do that rather easily even if we
do like we will have to write up we will
have to write up in gel code basically
what i'm saying because we don't have a
renderer yep it's not obstructed but
once we do have a renderer on once that
is abstracted we'll be able to convert
that i'm go away on that i'm glad that
i'm going to render essentially to use
hazel's api and that'll be awesome to
get it'll mean for
we'll have one kind of I'm doing
rendering implementation for all
rendering api's like once we have
DirectX and everything it'll just be
just be great but also also it will be
it'll kind of will in general just
you'll just use hazel and so just using
raw OpenGL calls which we which we don't
want to do anyway so that's going to be
the plan for the next episode should be
kind of quick and Daddy but I do want to
get it in because when we are building
our render our being able to have a UI
it's gonna be really important that's
why I cannot want to do this first cool
hope you guys enjoy this video I'll see
in the next one
good bye
[Music]